ian mckellen was one of the most
recognizable actors of the early 2000s
having instantly cemented himself as a
geek icon with his performances as
gandalf the grey
and magneto today though he's not so
much of a presence in hollywood
so just where has he gone when actors
are young
they tend to be hungry for creative and
professional validation
and often have to work incredibly hard
to establish their career
when actors are older however or more
comfortable financially
they usually have different priorities
considering the number of major films
ian mckellen has starred in over the
past 20 years alone
it's probably safe to assume that he's
pretty financially well-off
as such he doesn't have to take every
part offered to him
in fact if he doesn't want to he
probably doesn't have to take
any parts at all and can simply spend
his time however he sees fit
it's also worth pointing out that
mckellen is now more than 80 years old
working in hollywood isn't easy even
when you're young and it's entirely
possible that the rigors of film and
television production
are simply more difficult for him than
they might have been 20 years ago
nobody can say for sure of course but
it's definitely not impossible that
mckellen neither once nor needs to be
working
quite as much as he used to as a senior
citizen with a history of prostate
cancer
ian mckellen is part of a segment of the
population that is more susceptible than
most to covert 19.
so if mckellen seemed like he kept a low
profile during much of 2020
he had a pretty good reason thankfully
mccallum received his first shot of the
covered vaccine in december 2020
as a senior citizen mckellen was among
the first in line for a first dose of
the vaccination
i feel very special and
it's a very happy day this i'm a bit
euphoric in a press release issued
shortly afterwards mckellen said
i feel honored to have received the
kovit 19 vaccine
and i would urge anyone who has offered
the vaccine to take up the offer
i really hope that as more people get
vaccinated we will move further along
the path
back to a more normal way of life
particularly for the arts which have
suffered so much this year
infant item subject unknown is a kind of
film that could only have been produced
during the 2020 lockdown
it's a time loop story in the vein of
groundhog day and palm springs
shot with just an iphone and almost
solely carried by tori butler hutt
so far so unremarkable right well
infinitem does have at least one
surprising thing going for it
a cameo by sir ian mckellen his
character largely appears in some
in-universe documentary footage
which conveniently allowed mckellen to
shoot his role from the comfort and
safety of his own home
so there you have it if anyone tells you
ian mckellen spent his lockdown
twiddling his thumbs
infinitem is evidence to the contrary
although ian mckellen's film and
television acting career began in the
mid-1960s if you ask the average movie
fan the one word that pops to mind when
they hear his name
odds are they'll answer gandalf you
shall not pass
peter jackson's films based on the works
of j.r.r tolkien and especially the lord
of the rings
left a long lasting impression on
blockbuster cinema and pop culture
indeed it seems fair to suggest that a
number of the most successful fantasy
properties of the last two decades
would never have even seen the light of
day or it not for the success of the
lord of the rings
as the wizard gandalf the grey and later
gandalf the white
mckellen serves as a kind of mentor to
the story's protagonists
he also features in some of the
trilogy's most iconic scenes
including the battle against the balrog
of moria the defense of minas tirith
and the last stand at the gates of
mordor of course those movies came out
20 years ago and the on-screen
adventures of gandalf finally came to a
close with the battle of the five armies
back in 2014.
since mckellen's signature role has
effectively been exhausted
he simply isn't going to be as visible
in the pop culture zeiss geist as he
once was
any comic book movie fan will tell you
that it's very rare indeed for a
character to be solely associated with
just one actor
it was only inevitable then that the
legendary x-men villain magneto
would carry on his big screen adventures
with an actor other than ian mckellen
after recognizing the failure of 2006's
x-men the last stand and the limitations
of a gradually aging cast
fox decided to give their x-men universe
a soft reboot
in 2011 with the prequel x-men first
class
for this movie michael fassbender
officially took over the role of eric
lyncher
fassbender played magneto for eight
years until a corporate buyouts
necessitated that x-men dark phoenix
be the final installment in fox's x-men
universe
a time travel oriented storyline allowed
mckellen a brief return in 2014's x-men
days of future past but for all intents
and purposes
he gave up the role of magneto a long
time ago and now with marvel studios
moving forward with their own version of
the x-men sometime in the near future
you probably shouldn't expect to see
mckellen reprise his other iconic role
anytime soon
since movies only tend to run for a
couple of hours it can be easy to forget
just how much time and effort goes into
producing and promoting them
to put it in perspective films with the
budget and scope of say an x-men movie
generally require about six months to
shoot once you throw in all the
contractually obligated promotional
appearances
typically required of a starring actor
you can probably figure that the cast
have to devote a good year of their
lives to any single project
so if you add up the three movies in the
x-men trilogy plus days of future past
it appears that ian mckellen has
dedicated around four years to playing a
single character
and the lord of the rings required an
even greater commitment than that
as mckellen recently told gq i think
some of the actors who would have been
offered it before me were rather put off
by the idea
of having to live in new zealand for a
year again you've got all that time
shooting plus the promo tours
all stretching from 2001 to 2003 and
beyond
and then he did the whole thing all over
again with the hobbit a decade later
if anybody's earned a break from
starring in 10th pole blockbuster
franchises
it's this guy as you may have noticed
it's not the mid naughts anymore which
means that ian mckellen's tenure as one
of the world's most visible movie stars
has probably come and gone
but that doesn't mean he hasn't been
getting any work first of course you've
got cats
along with a huge cast of fellow
a-listers mckellen shows up in the
widely and colorfully criticized
adaptation
of the hit stage musical and while it
definitely isn't enough to save the film
his performance as gusta theater cats is
guaranteed to delight fans of the
musical
young kids and stoners alike mckellen
also appears in 2019's the good liar
a modestly budgeted con artist thriller
directed by bill condon
also starring helen mirren though hardly
a smash hit
the good liar racked up a 63 fresh
rotten tomatoes rating
which means at the very least that
critics liked it a heck of a lot more
than cats
in the movie mckellen plays a grifter
who attempts to liberate a large sum of
money from mirren's character
via a disingenuous romance and sure it's
not the best movie in the world
but the two stars at least seem to be at
the top of their game as the observer
noted in its review of the movie
the way they'd listen look into each
other's eyes absorb each word in every
silence while sipping a flute of
champagne or sharing a cup of tea
it's a revelation and a masterclass in
acting and the royal academy of dramatic
art at the same time
together they redefine rapture while
most people associate ian mckellen with
his acting roles
for a few decades now he has also been a
leading activist in the uk's lgbt
community
back in the late 1980s the section 28
law made discussing homosexuality in
schools illegal
and mckellen a famous uk actor even
before his later hit movies
came out in the media in protest i've
never met a gay person
who regrets coming out since then he has
co-founded the stonewall charity
organization
and now serves as a patron for multiple
other lgbt rights groups
in his interview with gq mckellen spoke
about his ongoing activism telling the
publication
i do hear people say when i was growing
up there were never any transgender
people about
well there were you just didn't notice
them and that was exactly what they used
to say about gay people
when an actor who was once prevalent in
hollywood makes fewer and fewer
appearances in movies
you might assume they're having
difficulty getting work sometimes that's
true of course but in this case you'd be
way off base
for mckellen recent years have seen him
spending more time than ever on the
stage
for example between 2015 and 2020
mckellan played the lead role in
multiple productions of king lear
co-starred in a production of no man's
land alongside patrick stewart
and even pulled off a spoken word comedy
show while american moviegoers might
think ian mckellen begins and ends with
gandalf and magneto
it's quite a different story on the
other side of the pond in the uk he's
more like an actor who begins and ends
with the theater
and makes a little room for gandalf and
magneto every now and then
hamlet revenant was first announced back
in 2017
and it doesn't appear as though a ton of
progress has been made since
nonetheless the movie to be sits at the
very top of ian mckellen's imdb page
which slice the film is still being in
pre-production according to variety
hamlet revenant is an original
adaptation of the legendary shakespeare
play
mckellen's role is unconfirmed so far
but connie nielsen of wonder woman fame
is signed on as gertrude alongside
mickel beau falls guard as a titular
angst ridden prince
with any luck hamlet revenant will come
together sometime soon
hollywood hasn't really committed to
shakespeare since the 90s
and the world has long overdue for a few
new spins on the bard's classics
and who better to lead the charge from
one of the great shakespearean actors of
his time
the character of hamlet is generally
depicted as a younger man in fact he's
occasionally cited as a straight-up
metaphor for adolescents
but is that going to start being
mckellen from picking up poor yorick's
skull and giving the role his all
heck no originally delayed by the kovit
19 lockdown
the theater royal windsor's production
of hamlet is scheduled to run from june
to september of 2021
which should keep mckellen in his
capacity as a titular depressed prince
very busy indeed of course you might
argue that mckellen's age might make
hamlet's youthful struggles a little
more difficult to believe
then again it could be that his age will
do wonders for the kind of existential
dread that's so crucial for a really
great performance as the infamous dane
whatever the case mckellen sounded
optimistic in the show's press release
in which he said
how can hamlet be played by an 80 year
old i hope theatre starved audiences
will want to find out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
you